everyone knows about german history
right
it's everywhere
books movies and monuments
germans have used everything to expose
and examine their past
and their guilt
but one particularly dark chapter does
not get as much attention
the country's colonial history
most germans we approached here in
berlin couldn't find their country's
former colonies
on a map
here
so why do germans know so little about
their colonial history before world war
one
the german empire was the third biggest
in the world
the colonies covered regions that are
now these countries
imperial germany sent troops to control
the colonies they brutalized local
people
and used them as fast workers and
soldiers
they ship thousands abroad as slaves and
they plundered the colonies
exporting things like ivory diamonds and
coker when the herrero and nama people
in present-day namibia rebelled
the germans slaughtered them
best estimates suggest german imperial
troops killed up to 100
000 people it was the first genocide of
the 20th century
the riches of empire were concentrated
in small pockets of germany
like hamburg
it was home to the trade and shipping
industries connecting
germany with its colonies the prophets
turned hamburg into a metropolis
second only to the capital berlin
[Music]
both cities still have street names and
monuments in memory of the colonies
and the men behind them
there is no way it could be forgotten in
africa but in germany
which profited so greatly there are two
main reasons why people know very little
one of them is the education system
from colonialism
buildings universities is
these are two popular history school
books for 16 to 18 year olds
they only have a few pages on
colonialism and the content
is less than enlightening
we looked at other history books and
school curricula some had nothing at all
on colonial history
and those that did had very little
if we compare internationally in most
societies the colonial past is not very
present
but it's probably even more so in
germany and that's
for a variety of reasons one of them
being that
in in germany the colonial past um
ended just much longer ago than
elsewhere and for that reason
it has largely you know been forgotten
in public discourse
the second reason is clearly the role of
the holocaust and public memory in the
german context the holocaust
is the dominant memory and that has
led to the marginalization of all kinds
of other memories
individual teachers often face that
dilemma alone
in history lessons that must cover the
holocaust how much of the remaining
teaching time
should they dedicate to colonialism
often they stick
to the prescribed curriculum which
doesn't give much space to colonial
history
the black lives matter movement in
germany says this ignorance of the
colonial era is important
they say it's one reason for today's
structural racism
is
um kint
dysglycine mindsets and the glycine
dengpeo
many suggest that because germans
generally don't examine that error
they don't challenge the thinking that
has come from it
the
germans are changing some street names
and are starting to discuss
what to do with colonial statues some
feel they don't fit into a modern
country
because they honor the perpetrators of
historical crimes
rather than mocking what they did or
giving voice to those they persecuted
the thought follows that making the
german colonial era part of the
country's collective memory
might help in tackling today's racism
there is sometimes a convenient way
of delegating the colonial issue to the
past
and that's a way of not speaking about
racism in the present
a wider understanding of colonial
history could help today's debates
but would people be interested at the
beginning
of
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you